good morning Hank it's Suzie I want to
begin by saying that this video contains
absolutely no spoilers whatsoever
well except insofar as just being alive
as a minor spoiler on account of how
you're connected to every other person
on earth a growing number of whom have
already seen the Star Wars movie and you
know they're now very slightly different
for having had that experience and
they're slight differences are causing
very slight differences in you and etc
as the force ripples through the
universe which is actually what I want
to talk about today so Hank I've now
seen the new Star Wars movie twice and I
really really like it and I'm trying to
figure out why all right this is Joseph
Campbell who wrote a famous book about
shared mythologies across cultures and
historical eras called the hero with a
thousand faces
basically camera pointed out that a lot
of our most important stories all
involve a plot where I'm just gonna
quote him a hero ventures forth from the
world of common day into a region of
supernatural wonder fabulous forces are
there encountered and a decisive victory
is won of course it can't be too
decisive because you know these are
movies and they need sequels but you get
the idea
Campbell's writing about shared
mythologies and mythological structures
was extremely influential to George
Lucas when he was writing the original
Star Wars movies and it shows I mean
Luke Skywalker follows the heroic
journey that Campbell laid out step by
step so I think the original Star Wars
trilogy is seen as important today not
just because they're good movies or
because the special effects and music
are amazing but because as myth they are
brilliant Luke Skywalker gave the hero
of a Thousand Faces yet one more face
and in his story I got to experience
that intoxicating mix of awe and
recognition that we seek from myth right
like recognition because I to have been
a petulant there do well in a boring
home town harboring a dream of going to
space and to all because like lord Vader
and the Death Star were intensely
awesome in the old-fashioned sense of
the word that involved fear but it's
also more than that like any good myth
Star Wars helps us to understand and
identify ourselves as people consider
for instance how much the assigning and
signalling of personhood matters in the
original Star Wars movies I mean we feel
bad for r2d2 who is a droid when he is
damaged
we also deeply empathize with Chewie
even though he is not a human and speaks
incomprehensibly we don't empathize with
the stormtroopers even though they're
humanoid and speak English because
they're not people they're actually
we didn't know what they were back in
1977 but we knew that they were not
proper people like us and Chewbacca now
of course the original Star Wars movies
did get their fair share of criticisms
people pointed out that the dialogue was
hokey that the galaxy was astonishingly
small and given over to unlikely
coincidence but for me all that stuff
was totally irrelevant I mean the
dialogue and Jonah's encountered with
the whale also leaves a bit to be
desired but that is so beside the point
and then the prequels came out and they
did not have the same mythic resonance
in fact for many people they were just
you know movies and as movies they
weren't particularly great honestly Hank
after those movies I felt like there
couldn't be another good Star Wars movie
because Star Wars had just given to the
common myth what it had to give great
the force awakens honors the myth of the
hero's journey from the original Star
Wars but it also expands and deepens it
along the way the movie pushes us toward
a broader understanding of personhood of
what constitutes us in fact think we saw
this in the first teaser footage
released months before the movie a
stormtrooper removes his helmet and
proves to have a very human face those
we could dismiss for the first six
movies are suddenly in arguably people
who are connected to us and in the movie
itself there's much more for instance we
see that the hero with a thousand faces
need not be male or white or even a
petulant Nair do well it's not a perfect
movie of course the galaxy is still
astonishingly small the dialogue still
sometimes clunky but it's a very
effective myth egg to be honest with you
I've been worried lately that I've grown
too old to properly love a movie I mean
they're just movies Hank I'll see you on
Friday in the meantime I'm just gonna
say it may the force be with you